hablemos ahora sobre los grupos de los
músculos no vamos a tomar mucho detalle
respecto a los nombres de cada músculo
sino el general de dónde se encuentran y
tengamos una noción cada vez que hagamos
estiramiento o vayamos al gimnasio saber
esto es importantísimo ya que nos va a
dar opciones para saber si están bien
trabajados nuestros músculos en cuanto a
balance tanto que el lado derecho esté
igual de fuerte que el izquierdo
etcétera hablaremos únicamente de 11
grupos en total que son los principales
para eso los vamos a dividir en brazo
con cuatro músculos principales cuatro
grupos de músculos principales pierna en
donde encontraremos tres grupos de
músculos
y el tronco
aquí tendremos también cuatro músculos
principales en el brazo notaremos
primero los músculos del antebrazo que
se notan mucho mejor viendo el cuerpo de
frente están aquí abajo justo arriba del
antebrazo se encuentran los bíceps
y es el que normalmente se considera
como fuerza en los brazos justo atrás de
los bíceps se encuentran los tríceps que
vamos a dibujarlos en un verde azul un
poquito más claro
y se encuentran justo aquí
encima de los bíceps y los tríceps
tenemos los hombros
este es el músculo de los hombros de
hecho se puede ver desde enfrente o
atrás pero por cuestiones de practicidad
los voy a dibujar únicamente por
enfrente así que aquí tenemos los cuatro
grupos principales del brazo si nos
vamos hacia las piernas encontramos
primero los cuádriceps porque el
cuádriceps de hecho cuádriceps indica
que tiene cuatro músculos trabajando
juntos en esta zona
y atrás de los cuádriceps existe un
músculo muy importante del cual quiero
hacer énfasis que son los muslos vamos a
dibujar los muslos aquí atrás y porque
quiero hacer énfasis porque estos
músculos normalmente se le olvidan a
mucha gente y luego tienden a hacer
ejercicios sin estirar los y ahí pueden
venir bastantes complicaciones abajo de
los muslos están los gemelos que son
este par de músculos que se ven aquí en
la pantorrilla en la parte de atrás y si
se fijan en la parte de enfrente tenemos
un par de huesos que son la tibia y el
peroné los gemelos se encuentran en la
parte de atrás vámonos con los músculos
del tronco justo aquí en el centro
tenemos lo que muchos llaman lavadero o
que quieren hacerse cuadritos son los
abdominales arriba y en la parte de
enfrente está el pecho este también es
un músculo que se trabaja mucho en el
gimnasio y la protección sobre todo
el tórax también tenemos músculos
principales en la parte de atrás
digamos que paralelos en los que
acabamos de ver está el trapezoide que
tiene una forma como de diamante más o
menos así y éste ayuda para el cuello y
también se conoce como espalda alta
abajo de este músculo se encuentra
también un músculo muy grande que
parecieran alitas que sale aquí como
alitas y se extiende hasta abajo
normalmente cuando la gente dice que se
ha lastimado la espalda se refiere este
músculo y tiende a tocarse la espalda
baja este músculo se llama dorsal ancho
así que estos son los once grupos de
músculos vamos a repasar los uno a uno
para que rápidamente los volvamos a
identificar hombro bíceps antebrazos y
tríceps con estos tenemos los cuatro
correspondientes al brazo nos vamos con
la pierna cuádriceps muslo y gemelos con
eso tenemos los tres correspondientes a
la pierna
y en el frente tenemos pecho y
abdominales y en la parte posterior del
cuerpo justo en la espalda tenemos
trapezoide
dorsal ancho así es que aquí tenemos los
once grupos principales de músculos en
el cuerpo